in this video I want to talk about what
is easily one of the most fundamental
and profound concepts in statistics and
maybe in all of mathematics and that's
the central limit theorem central limit
theorem and what it tells us is we could
start off with any distribution that has
a well-defined mean and variance and if
it has a well-defined variance it has a
well-defined standard deviation and it
could be a continuous distribution or
discrete one I'll draw a discrete one
just because it's easier to imagine at
least for the purposes of this video so
let's say I have a discrete probability
distribution function and I want to be
very careful not to make it look
anything close to a normal distribution
because I want to show you the power of
the central limit theorem so let's say I
have a distribution let's say it can
take on values 1 through 6 1 2 3 4 5 6
it's some kind of crazy dice that's very
likely to get a 1 let's say it's
impossible let me make that a straight
line
your very high likelihood of getting one
let's say it's impossible to get a 2
let's say it's an ok likely to being a 3
or 4 let's say it's impossible to get a
5 let's say it's very likely to get a 6
like that so that's my probability
distribution function if I were to draw
a mean this is symmetric so maybe the
mean would be something like that the
mean would be halfway so that would be
my mean right there the standard
deviation maybe we would look it'd be
that far and that far above and below
the mean but that's my discrete
probability distribution function now
what I'm going to do here instead of
just taking samples of this random
variable that's described by this
probability distribution function I'm
going to take samples of it but I'm
going to average the samples and then
look at those samples and see the
frequency of the averages that I get and
when I say average I mean the mean so
let's say let me define something let's
say my sample size and I could put any
number here but let's say first off we
try a sample size of n is equal to 4 and
what that means is I'm going to take 4
samples from this so let's say the first
time I take 4 samples so my sample size
is 4 let's say I get a 1 let's say I get
another one
and let's say I get a 3 and I get a 6 so
that right there is my first sample
of sample size four and I know the
terminology can get confusing because
this is a sample that's made up of four
samples but in when we talk about the
sample mean and the sampling
distribution of the sample mean which
we're going to talk more and more about
over the next few videos
normally the sample refers to the set of
samples from your distribution and the
sample size tells you how many you
actually took from your distribution but
the terminology can be very confusing
because you could easily confuse as a
sample but we're taking four samples
from here we have a sample size of four
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
average them so let's say the the mean I
want to be very careful when I say
average the mean of this first sample of
size 4 is what 1 plus 1 is 2 2 plus 3 is
5 5 plus 6 is 11 11 divided by 4 is what
2 point seven five two point seven five
that is my first sample mean for my
first sample of size 4 let me do another
one
my second sample of size 4 let's say
that I get a three for a let's say get
another 3 and let's say I get a 1
I just didn't happen to get a 6 that
time and notice I can't get a 2 or a 5
it's impossible for this distribution
the chance of getting a 2 or 5 is 0 so I
can't have any twos or fives over here
so in this for the second sample of
sample size for my sample mean for my
second so my second sample mean is going
to be 3 plus 4 7 7 plus 3 is 10 plus 1
is 11 11 divided by 4 once again is 2.75
let me do one more because I really want
to make it clear what we're doing here
so I do one more actually going to do a
gazillion more but let me just do one
more in detail so let's say my third
sample of sample size 4 I get so I'm
going to literally take 4 samples so my
sample is made up of 4 samples from this
an original crazy distribution let's say
I get a 1 a 1 and a 6 and a 6 and so my
third sample mean is going to be 1 plus
1 is 2 2 plus 6 is 8 8 plus 6 is 14 14
divided by 4 14 divided by 4 is what 3
a half three and a half and as I find
each of these sample means so I eat for
each of my samples of sample size for I
figure out a mean and as I do each of
them I'm going to plot it on a frequency
distribution and this is all going to
amaze you in a few seconds
so I've plot this all on a frequency
distribution so I say okay on my first
sample my first sample mean was two
point seven five so I'm plotting the
actual frequency of the sample means I
get for each sample so two point seven
five I got at one time so I'll put a
little plot there so that's from that
one right there and I got the next time
I also got a two point seven five that's
a two point seven five there so I'll so
I got twice so I'll plot the frequency
right there then I got a three and a
half so all the possible values I could
have a three I could have a three point
two five I could have a three and a half
so then I have the three and a half so
I'll plot it right there and what I'm
going to do is I'm going to keep taking
these samples maybe I'll take you know
maybe I'll take ten thousand of them so
I'm going to keep taking these samples
so I go all the way to s you know ten
thousand I just do a bunch of these and
what's going to look like over time is
each of these I'm going to make it a dot
because I'm gonna have to zoom out so if
I look at it like this over time it's
tell us all the values that it might be
able to take on you know two point seven
five might be here so this first dot
this first dot is going to be this one
right here is going to be right there
and that second one is going to be right
there and that one at three point five
is going to look right there but I'm
gonna do it ten thousand times going to
have ten thousand dots and let's say as
I do it I'm going to just keep plotting
them I'm just going to keep plotting the
frequencies I'm just going to keep
plotting them over and over and over
again and what you're going to see is as
I take many many samples of size four
I'm going to have something that's going
to start kind of approximating a normal
distribution so each of these dots
represent an incidence of a sample mean
so as I keep adding on this column right
here that means I kept getting the
sample mean two point seven five so over
time I'm going to have something that's
starting to approximate a normal
distribution and that is the neat thing
about the central limit theorem so the
central limit to end this was the case
this was the case for so in orange that
the case for n is equal to four this was
a four sample size of four now if I did
the same thing with the sample size of
maybe 20 so in this case instead of just
taking four samples from my original
crazy distribution every sample I take
twenty instances of my random variable
and I average those twenty and then I
plot the sample mean on here so in that
case I'm going to have a distribution
that looks like this and we'll discuss
this in more videos but it turns out if
I were to plot the sample 10,000 of the
sample means here I'm going to have
something that two things it's going to
even more closely approximate a normal
distribution and we're going to see in
future videos it's actually going to
have a smaller well let me let me be
clear it's going to have a small it's
going to have the same mean so that's
the mean this is going to have the same
mean that's going to have a smaller
standard deviation so I want to well I
should plot these from the bottom
because you kind of stack it when you
get one and another instance in another
instance but this is going to more and
more approach a normal distribution so
the the reality is and this is what's
super cool about the central limit
theorem as your sample size as your
sample size as your sample size becomes
larger you can even say as it approaches
infinity but you really don't have to
get that close to infinity to really get
close to a normal distribution even if
you have a sample size of 10 or 20
you're already getting very close to a
normal distribution in fact you know
about as good an approximation as we see
in our everyday life but what's cool is
we can start with some crazy
distribution right this isn't this has
nothing to do with the normal
distribution but if we have a sample
size this was N equals 4 but if you have
a sample size of N equals 10 or N equals
100 and we were to take a hundred of
these instead of 4 here and average them
and then plot that average the frequency
of it then we do take 100 again
average them take the mean plot that
again and if we would do that a bunch of
times in fact if we would do that an
infinite time we would find that we
especially if we had an infinite sample
size we would find a perfect normal
distribution that's the crazy thing and
it doesn't apply just to taking the
sample mean here we took the sample mean
every time but you could have also taken
the sample sum the cent the central
limit theorem would have still applied
but that's what's so super useful about
it because in life there's all sorts of
process
is out there proteins bumping into each
other you know people doing crazy things
humans interacting in weird ways and you
don't know the probability distribution
functions for any of those things but
the central limit theorem tells us is
that if we add a bunch of those actions
together assuming that they all have the
same distribution or if we were to take
the mean of all of those actions
together and if we were to plot the
frequency of those means we do get a
normal distribution and that's frankly
why the normal distribution shows up so
much so much in statistics and why
frankly it's a very good approximation
for the sum or the means of a lot of
processes normal distribution what I'm
going to show you in the next video is
I'm actually showing you that this is a
reality that as you increase your sample
size as you increase your N and as you
take a lot of sample means you're going
to have a frequency plot that looks very
very close to a normal distribution